[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7 8 sur TV 78
c'est votre émission pour bien démarrer
la soirée dans les Yvelines avec au
programme de l'actualité des infos
pratiques et des idées de sortie voici
le programme de ce 24 janvier
il y a quelques jours le tribunal
judiciaire de Versailles faisait son
audience solennel l'occasion de faire le
bilan de l'année 2022 et de se projeter
sur 2023 entre 2019 et 2022 le nombre de
procédures a bondit de plus de 3,5% sans
pour autant que les moyens augmentent
pour la justice invité exceptionnelle
Maryvonne Caillebotte procureur de la
République de Versailles
tout au long du mois de janvier période
traditionnelle des vœux TV 78 reçoit les
maires de 50 ans en Yvelines pour parler
des grands projets de l'année 2023 dans
leur ville ce soir focus sur la ville de
Magny-les-Hameaux nous aborderons
plusieurs thématiques avec le maire de
la commune Bertrand Houillon qui est
notre invité et puis le nouvel an
chinois a démarré depuis à dimanche les
festivités pour l'année du Lapin d'eau
vont se poursuivre jusqu'au 5 février à
cette occasion l'astuce du chef
métalonneur ce soir une recette chinoise
le gâteau de riz sauté sousouillet du
restaurant faux 78 à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux vous donne ses
conseils pour réussir ce flasher vous
mais avant de développer ces titres
direction tout de suite l'université
Versailles 50 ans en Yvelines et plus
précisément la Bibliothèque
Universitaire de Guyancourt vous le
voyez on retrouve sur place Régine rage
de la rédaction de TV 78 puisque l'UVSQ
régime et son président font ce soir
leur vœux leur vœux 203
bonsoir Grégory alors oui effectivement
ce soir c'est la cérémonie des vœux et
j'ai avec moi monsieur Alain nuit le
président d'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines bonsoir
bonsoir alors ce soir vous allez
prononcer vos vœux c'est un moment
important pour clore l'année 2022 c'est
également important pour 2023 comment
est-ce que vous abordez justement cette
nouvelle année et qu'est-ce que vous
retenez également de l'année 2022 le
sujet important c'est la finalisation de
la construction de l'université
Paris-Saclay avec l'intégration pleine
et entière de l'Université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans ce grand
projet sur lequel nous travaillons déjà
depuis plus de 10 ans
justement et vous avez un grand projet à
l'horizon 2025 c'est la fusion de
l'université paris-saclet cette année ce
qu'il y a de grandes étapes justement à
franchir quant à ce projet là et c'est
exactement ce que nous avons commencé en
2022 et qu'on va confirmer en 2023 alors
nous sommes pas dans un une logique de
fusion classique au sens du terme et
donc on l'appelle on a précisé
exactement que le devenir de
l'Université de versa 50 ans divine dans
le cadre de Versailles de Paris-Saclay
et donc ce sera une intégration pleine
et entière donc on va conserver nos
campus et on va changer nos statuts et
on va aussi changer notre nom et donc on
est on y travaille donc on s'appellera
Université Paris Saclay tiré quelque
chose qui représentera forcément
Versailles et les Yvelines par exemple
qui n'est pas encore défini aujourd'hui
mais c'est très important donc ça montre
le côté irréversible quelque part de
notre participation projet Paris Saclay
aujourd'hui c'est la date anniversaire
du lancement du premier nano satellite
uvsq7 il a été lancé il y a deux ans
donc le 24 janvier 2021
ruban est prévu en avril est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire quelques mots oui
alors c'est effectivement deux ans en
fait c'est exactement le jour pour jour
2 ans le lancement de ce premier nano
satellite un projet universitaire et le
second avec la même équipe donc je
rappelle du laboratoire l'Atmos ici qui
a l'observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est juste
derrière ici et le lancement la mission
orbite aura lieu très bientôt et
probablement dans les toutes prochaines
semaines donc je sais pas encore au
briser quelle date mais c'est imminent
donc c'est vraiment une grande fierté
qui symbolise la capacité à notre
université d'être très proactive au
niveau de la recherche
merci beaucoup Alain vie et je rappelle
vous êtes le président de l'université
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui
présente ses vœux ce soir à la
bibliothèque universitaire à Guyancourt
merci Régine Rollès avec Céline Charlot
au moyen technique depuis la
Bibliothèque Universitaire de Guyancourt
de l'UVSQ alors pour ce 7 8 autour de la
table il y a des invités je le disais
dans les titres Maryvonne Caillebotte
est avec nous bonsoir bonsoir procureur
de la République de Versailles on
parlera avec vous dans un instant de la
justice de ses procédures qui ont
augmenté au cours de l'année 2022 à vos
côtés il y a Valentin Delaporte bonsoir
vous êtes vous le directeur adjoint de
la Bergerie Nationale le site va
organiser un ses portes ouvertes ce sera
samedi pour présenter l'ensemble des
formations sera aussi l'occasion de
revenir sur les ovinsiades qui sont
déroulés la semaine dernière à la
Bergerie Nationale et puis les
journalistes de la rédaction de TV 78
Gabriel Montier bonsoir avez-vous dans
un instant les informations du jour à
retenir de ce mardi 24 janvier et
également Nicolas dandry bonsoir bonsoir
et avec vous on va voir aussi dans un
instant on va parler de problématique
judiciaire mais aussi on va revenir sur
le déplacement du ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin s'est rendu
hier dans la commune des Bréviaires et
le département pourrait bientôt
accueillir deux nouvelles brigades de
gendarmerie supplémentaires sont en tout
cas les vœux qui ont été hier émis
auprès du ministre sans oublier bien sûr
dans un sol si les insolites de
Véronique vous avez l'habitude de ce
rendez-vous maintenant à chaque mardi
les news insolites qu'il fallait retenir
dans le territoire des Yvelines mais
d'abord on va regarder vos prévisions
météo de demain
[Musique]
finalement des conditions météo
semblables à celles d'aujourd'hui il y
aura également peut-être demain du
brouillard dans les Yvelines demain
matin côté température il fera moins un
degré moins 1 degré à Mantes-la-Jolie ou
dans et Rambouillet 0° à Versailles dans
l'après-midi quelques éclaircis prévus
mais ça reste froid il fera à 2 degrés à
Versailles un degré à Rambouillet et
Houdan et ce mercredi 25 janvier nous
fêterons les Paul
[Musique]
les informations du jour avec vous
Gabriel Gontier on commence par cette
opération de rapatriement avec une
arrivée ce matin dans les Yvelines une
arrivée ce matin avec un avion pas comme
les autres qui s'est posé à l'aéroport
de militaire de Vélizy
Vélizy-Villacoublay à son bord 15
djihadistes françaises et 32 enfants
Grégory après avoir appartenu au rang de
l'organisation état islamique ils
étaient détenus dans les camps de force
kurde c'est le premier rapatriement de
l'année 2023 le dernier avait eu lieu le
20 octobre dernier les femmes ont été
confiées aux autorités judiciaires de
leur côté les enfants ont été remis au
service de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
ce matin quelle est la suite judiciaire
suite à cette information aujourd'hui
alors comme vous l'avez rappelé en fait
il y a deux canaux d'une certaine
manière il y a les femmes qui ont été
prises en charge judiciairement par le
parquet national anti-terroriste donc il
ne concerne pas du tout le parquet de
Versailles et puis il y a le devenir des
32 enfants qui ont été accueillis
temporairement sur le département des
Yvelines et qui ont vocation en fait à
rejoindre d'autres territoires
en région qui correspondent soit leur
dernière localisation de leur famille ou
à délocalisation de la famille élargie
ils seront pris en charge du point de
vue de l'assistance éducatif
c'est-à-dire leur éducation lorsque la
réalisation les soins dont ils auront
besoin pour cette actualité une autre
actualité qui concerne cette fois-ci
Gabriel le porte-monnaie de certains
habitants de Coignières oui pour faire
face à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
une allocation énergie de 70 euros et
proposé par le Centre communal d'action
sociale de la ville de Coignières alors
cette aide elle est destination des plus
précaires les familles nombreuses
monoparentales ou encore les personnes
âgées et bien d'autres vous retrouverez
les conditions sur le site de la commune
ainsi que le formulaire d'inscription
attention le dossier doit être transmis
avant le 27 janvier à noter que d'autres
villes de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
proposent cette aide comme Guyancourt
par exemple si vous avez d'autres
questions le contact téléphonique du
Centre Communal d'Action Sociale
s'affiche en bas de l'écran le chiffre
du jour Gabriel lui concerne les
transports oui l'addition est élevée 200
millions d'euros c'est le montant des
dépenses complémentaires à financer par
Île-de-France mobilité à l'occasion des
JO de Paris 2024 la raison le premier
appel d'offre lancé en juillet n'a pas
reçu deux réponses de la part des
acteurs de la mobilité s'ajoutent à cela
la tension sur les prix et les effectifs
dans les transports conséquences la
facture est importante et des problèmes
d'organisation à apparaissent les
personnes accréditées n'ont pas encore
de mode de transport l'augmentation elle
s'explique égale également par
l'exploitation et l'allongement de
certaines lignes comme le RER E la ligne
14 ou encore la ligne 11 on vient à
présent sur cette affaire de fraude qui
concerne un centre dentaire à Trappes
oui le Centre Dentaire mediental de
Trappes ouverts en 2021 est visé par des
soupçons de fraudes ce sont les patients
qui ont fait part de leur étonnement
face à des systèmes de double
facturation le préjudice célébrait à un
million d'euros sur 9 mois d'activités
le centre révisé par un retrait de
conventionnement pour 5 ans à compter du
premier février 2023 une plainte a été
déposée en attendant l'enquête pénale
les soins ne sont plus pris en charge
par assurance maladie et ça c'est une
première en France on termine avec une
information qui est presque passée
inaperçue oui et pourtant car ça fait
des années que le sujet revient dans les
discussions vous n'avez pas pu l'éviter
si vous habitez Orgeval ou si vous avez
l'habitude de circuler dans les
alentours l'ancien restaurant chinois
Palace d'Orgeval situé à l'entrée de la
de la ville d'Orgeval sur la rdc13 va
disparaître à l'abandon couvert de tags
et de graffitis sa réhabilitation était
bloquée en raison du prix de vente
proposée par le restaurateur alors
finalement la vente aura lieu d'après
nos confrères du statut cactus c'est un
rond-point qui devrait voir le jour ce
qui permettrait de réhabiliter l'entrée
de la ville qui est souvent bouchée avec
un trafic important merci Gabriel et si
vous aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoin d'une information d'un fait qui
vous fait réagir n'hésitez pas à le dire
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 7 8 news
et on lisait tout à l'heure Nicolas
dandry le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin s'est rendu hier dans la
commune des Bréviaires c'est non loin de
Rambouillet l'objectif se lancer une
concertation dans les territoires pour
déterminer l'implantation de 200
nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie d'ici
à la fin de l'année dans les territoires
les plus en tension et vous revenez
justement sur sur ce déplacement
effectivement Grégory se déplacement
s'inscrit vraiment dans un tour de
France du ministre de l'Intérieur dans
chaque département il va voir les
besoins qu'on les acteurs locaux des
territoires en termes d'effectifs de
gendarmerie et donc hier il était au
bréviaire dans les Yvelines où il a pu
échanger avec les élus locaux sur leur
problématique en termes de sécurité
notamment dans les zones rurales on est
vraiment le maillon de la citoyenneté la
proximité le maire reste le référent
territorial sur sur son territoire voilà
c'est vraiment la tâche l'ancrage
territorial le maire sa brigade de
gendarmerie c'est vraiment essentiel
voilà c'est deux liens importants sur le
territoire je pense qu'il y a une
évolution de la population une évolution
des délits on a beaucoup plus de dépôts
sauvages on a beaucoup plus
d'incivilités on a beaucoup plus de
d'incivilités voire d'atteinte aux
personnes des problèmes de stationnement
tout ça c'est lié à l'augmentation de la
population et pour ça il faut des moyens
il faut de la présence et je pense que
le lien entre gendarmerie et police
municipale et probablement un élément de
solution très important
concernant dans les Yvelines et bien
deux nouvelles brigades de gendarmerie
devraient être créés parmi les 200
créations à l'échelle de nationale
l'objectif était de renforcer l'objectif
étant de renforcer le maillage
territorial des gendarmes dans les
Yvelines et on écoute à ce propos le
colonel Vincent roche au micro de Julien
Leroy l'augmentation de la délinquance
et les mutations surtout que la
délinquance connaît à travers les axes
principaux de circulation routier
ferroviaires mais aussi le nouvel
frontières et surtout les enjeux
environnementaux qui sont très prégnants
aujourd'hui nous conduit à solliciter
des implantations supplémentaires afin
de mieux prendre en compte les nouvelles
problématiques auxquelles nous devons
faire face alors les zones qui
retiennent plus particulièrement notre
attention et qui ont été présentés aux
élus cet après-midi sont des zones qui
vont voir un développement démographique
conséquent dans les années à venir et
qui retiennent notre attention pour la
raison de d'aller vers une population
toujours grandissante c'est également
les lieux où les bassins de délinquance
sont implantés de manière structurelle
et à présent Nicolas quelle est la suite
du processus alors pour le moment on ne
sait pas où vont être situés et
installés ces brigades alors en termes
de calendrier des propositions ont été
émises donc dans l'après-midi hier à
travers les échanges avec le ministre de
l'intérieur mais les propositions
finales d'implantation ben ce sera le
préfet des Yvelines Jean-Jacques Baud
qui le fera et bien court en mars et
ensuite le ministère de l'Intérieur
tranchera et rendra public sa liste des
200 créations de brigades de gendarmerie
cours en mai et le déploiement devrait
se faire durant l'été 2023 merci Nicolas
on vient de l'entendre Maryvonne
Caillebotte les élus locaux constatent
une évolution de la délinquance dans les
zones rurales elle parle aussi des
moyens à supplémentaires nécessaires
pour y faire face par rapport à la
délinquance en zone rurale quel constat
vous faites au tribunal judiciaire de
Versailles alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que le tribunal judiciaire de
Versailles est alimenté à je dirais 75%
d'abord par ce qu'on appelle les zones
polices alors que le territoire du
département des Yvelines est
essentiellement est très essentiellement
un terr rural donc qui est captée par la
gendarmerie pour autant ces zones sont
tout à fait concernés par la délinquance
et d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qu'on
observe ici comme dans beaucoup de
territoire dit ruraux et donc il
convient effectivement et ça d'ailleurs
été très bien rappelé dans le reportage
d'être vraiment présent les gendarmes se
positionne vers cette présence auprès
notamment des maires qui effectivement
sont très demandeurs et de la population
et on voit une délinquance montée pas
partout mais dans certains territoires
et le positionnement de ces brigades a
une cohérence effectivement par rapport
à ces données donc de nouvelles brigades
dans dans les Yvelines alors vous avez
tenu aussi l'audience solennelle avec le
président du tribunal judiciaire de
Versailles Bertrand menest et vendredi
dernier et globalement quel message vous
souhaitiez faire passer lors de ce
rendez-vous j'avais déjà un message de
plaisir à faire passer qui était la
possibilité de tenir enfin une audience
solennelle de rentrer en grand format
c'est à dire d'accueillir tout nos
partenaires nos collaborateurs ou les
gens avec lesquels on travaille au
quotidien c'est important c'est une fois
dans donc c'est rare donc c'est précieux
et puis peut-être un petit peu plus
sérieusement mais non moins sincèrement
ce que je voulais faire passer c'était
en prenant un exemple au delà des
chiffres de d'augmentation de l'un des
délinquance mais je dirais c'est une
progression que l'on retrouve assez
normalement après la période covid on
n'a pas tout à fait retrouvé les niveaux
de 2019 mais ça remonte vraiment très
sérieusement c'est sur la base du
contentieux des violences
intra-familiales de montrer que on ne
pouvait pas imaginer d'absorber un
contentieux qui explose de cette manière
là à coup zéro
avant de revenir justement sur entrer
dans les détails par rapport aux
violences familiales j'aimerais revenir
sur une citation qui moi m'a marqué
j'étais présent lors de cette audience
solennelle je vous cite nous avons le
sens du service public et quoi qu'il en
coûte sachant que le nouveau parler des
magistrats et des fonctionnaires du
tribunal judiciaire donc je reprends
nous avons le sens du service public et
quoi qu'il en coûte nous avons toujours
envie que l'institution fonctionne
peut-être qu'un jour ça nous perdra et
ce phénomène a peut-être déjà commencé
fin de citation
qu'est-ce qu'elle raconte cette phrase
en fait quelle est la réalité
aujourd'hui du tribunal judiciaire de
Versailles alors en tant que procureur
de la République je parle plus
particulièrement des magistrats du
parquet ce que je souhaite dire par ce
genre de propos c'est que c'est aussi un
écho à la fameuse tribune qui évidemment
a pris beaucoup d'ampleur et beaucoup de
place dans nos discussions et dans nos
juridictions et qui a montré que
justement cette ce métier qui nous
dépasse en fait et pour lequel on peut
déployer beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup
d'heures beaucoup de travail sans
forcément avoir
la rémunération qui va bien et la
reconnaissance qui va bien on est
peut-être effectivement dans une période
de changement par rapport à ça et la
nécessité de reconnaître que un travail
mérite sa récompense quel que soit ce
travail évidemment et que donc il faut
et là je rejoins un petit peu ce que je
disais reconnaître que cette envie de
que ça fonctionne en y mettant du temps
et de l'énergie et bien ça ne peut pas
se faire sans un certain nombre de
moyens juste pour que nos
téléspectateurs comprennent madame la
procureur vient de parler d'une tribune
en fait l'année dernière c'était en
novembre 2021 et bien il y a 3000
magistrats et puis en plus c'est bon
tribune en fait dans la presse pour
appeler et bien aux conditions
compliquées un exercice de leur activité
et ça ça faisait suite en fait à une
magistrate une de vos collègues qui
s'était et bien suicidé à l'été 2021
aujourd'hui il y a des cas de Burn Out
au tribunal judiciaire Versailles il y a
des situations assez délicates en termes
de conditions de travail et de santé des
collaborateurs la santé les conditions
de travail au tribunal de judiciaire de
Versailles sont une préoccupation qui
est très importante pour le président et
moi-même et donc nous essayons autant
que faire ce peu d'avoir connaissance de
ces conditions et de la qualité avec
laquelle enfin les magistrats et les
fonctionnaires peuvent travailler en
plus nous sommes soutenus en cela par
les chefs de cours qui ont pris ce ce
sujet à bras le corps et qui ont déployé
recruté et déployer des psychologues
spécialisés qui sont à disposition et à
demeure dans nos juridictions de façon à
être en capacité de recevoir les
personnes qui en ont besoin donc ce sont
des thématiques qui ont pris beaucoup de
place par rapport à ce que j'ai pu
connaître moi je dirais autrefois et
c'est tout à fait normal dans un
contexte on l'a rappelé un augmentation
des procédures vous êtes passés de 9065
procédures en 2019 à
93351 une augmentation d'environ 3,5%
sans pour autant qui est forcément de
moyens supplémentaires en face est-ce
que la solution viendra par une
augmentation justement de ces moyens
comme l'annoncer le ministre de la
Justice de garde des sceaux Eric
Dupont-Moretti 5 janvier dernier écoutez
le fait que le budget de la justice soit
spectaculairement augmenté et bien un
signe qu'il fallait un rattrapage ça je
pense que c'est un constat objectif de
base après si vous voulez le sujet des
moyens c'est toujours quelque chose qui
nous est reproché en disant vous ne
savez que joindre et demander davantage
ce qu'on peut constater c'est que quand
il y a des moyens la justice elle
fonctionne et si on prend quelques
process spectaculaires alors je fais
attention avec le mot spectaculaire mais
en tout cas des procès dit terroristes
qui ont lieu dernièrement ou la justice
est donnée les moyens d'avoir
matériellement et humainement la
capacité à les régler à rendre cette
justice et notamment je pense à des 13
et bien on voit que ça fonctionne donc
je dirais que c'est peut-être une
démonstration par le concret alors tout
à l'heure vous avez parlé des violences
intra familiales on peut dire que c'est
un peu le quotidien du tribunal de
l'activité pénale du Tribunal judiciaire
de Versailles parce que vous l'avez dit
durant l'audience solennelle c'est très
majoritairement ce contentieux là qui
vous concerne au quotidien et vous avez
même parlé que aujourd'hui vous êtes
quasiment dans une situation que
connaissent les urgences hospitalières
et que vous êtes obligé de traiter de
trier les affaires que que vous traitez
je crois qu'à 123 à faire actuellement
qui sont dans les armoires depuis 2020
et qui ne sont pas traités
qui attendent effectivement d'être jugé
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une audience pour
que les personnes auteurs ou victimes
puissent voir leur procès juger
effectivement alors les violences
intrafamiales ne sont pas le seul
contentieux que l'on traite au tribunal
judiciaire loin de là et je voudrais pas
que le doute s'installe par rapport à ça
c'est simplement ce que je voulais
montrer c'est une explosion vraiment
très très importante qui fait que ce
contentieux en fait c'est inséré dans
tous les contentieux que l'on traite
sans que les autres contentionnées
disparaissent et donc il les a
simplement fait reculer donc si on fait
reculer quelque chose et qu'on met
quelque chose devant c'est une forme de
prière et c'est mon rôle en tant que en
tant que chef de juridique son chef du
Parquet néanmoins ce n'est pas sans
conséquence tout à fait négative pour
ceux qui attendent alors pour rentrer
sur le fond du sujet des violences
intrafamilales c'est un sujet
d'importance en même dans le département
entier avec les différents acteurs vos
différents partenaires puisque deux fois
par an vous lissez ce qu'on appelle le
comité local d'edovic team et ce comité
local des doductible est vraiment dédié
à ces violences là effectivement dans le
département nous l'avons désacracation
dédiées aux violences intrafamiliales et
en ce début d'année nous avons même
ajouté une thématique et celle des
violences faites au milieu au mineur
pardon qu'elle soit dans ce contexte là
ou dans un contexte ni plus ni moins
grave très grave qui est celui des
violences sexuelles qui doivent être
traitées et qui méritent d'être traités
outre ce contentieux particulier donc
effectivement c'est une thématique
importante
et qui est naturel de traiter et je l'ai
dit vendredi dernier c'est même une
fierté à un honneur pour un état de
droit que de traiter enfin ce
contentieux-là simplement ce qu'il faut
bien savoir c'est que il ne suffit pas
d'avoir des outils il ne suffit pas
d'avoir un téléphone grand danger un
bracelet anti-rapprochement il faut
derrière tous ces outils des personnes
pour suivre la mise en oeuvre et donc on
ne peut pas simplement dire aux
juridictions et bien vous avez tous les
moyens vous avez toutes les lois vous
avez tous les dispositifs maintenant ça
ne doit plus arriver ça n'est pas aussi
simple que ça un dernier mot quels sont
les grands rendez-vous à ne pas manquer
en 2023 pour le tribunal judiciaire de
Versailles et bien c'est continuer de
déployer son dynamisme son énergie
d'avoir des idées de défendre aussi ce
qu'il a besoin de défendre c'est-à-dire
de faire les demandes qui vont bien et
puis de s'intéresser aux conclusions des
États généraux qui vont d'une manière ou
d'une autre nous concerner notamment
s'agissant de la réforme ou de la
roquefortification pardon du code de
procédure pénale merci Maryvonne
Caillebotte je le rappelle procureur de
la République de Versailles merci
d'avoir été avec nous on l'a compris
jusqu'au 31 janvier c'est la période
pour souhaiter les vœux il est encore
temps de souhaiter bonne année TV 78
profite de cette période justement pour
aller à la rencontre des mères des douze
communes de 50 ans en Yvelines parler
avec eux des grands projets de l'année
dans leur commune la suite ce soir avec
la commune de Manille les hameaux et son
maire Bertrand Houillon l'entretien a
été enregistré cet après-midi
avec mon plateau Bertrand Houillon
bonsoir bonsoir mère de la commune de
Magny-les-Hameaux également l'un des
vice-président de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines alors vous avez présenté vous
vos vœux au manicois et manicois le 8
janvier on l'imagine une thématique qui
revient beaucoup dans toutes les têtes
en ce début d'année c'est celle de la
sobriété énergétique ensuite notamment à
la forte inflation comment la commune
fait-elle face à cette thématique et ce
qui a des choses qui sont prévues aussi
sur l'année 2023 en matière de sobriété
énergétique alors on a déjà engagé un
certain nombre d'actions depuis octobre
novembre dernier notamment sur les
réductions des chauffages sur une
attention particulière sur l'éclairage
on était déjà passé sur une bonne partie
de la commune sur l'ensemble de nos
hameaux sur de l'extinction de
l'éclairage public qu'on a qu'on a
étendu à l'ensemble à l'ensemble de la
commune
et on continue cette année par rapport
aussi à du changement de nos éclairages
dans les bâtiments communaux avec les
LED même si on l'avait commencé on va
l'accélérer tout simplement cette année
et puis on continue nos travaux de
rénovation énergétique qui sont un
élément important puisque pour donner un
exemple on est sur quasiment 60%
d'économie en consommation de chauffage
sur une école qui a été sur un centre de
loisirs qui a été rénové énergétiquement
donc c'est vraiment des enjeux très
forts on n'a pas attendu cette
problématique d'inflation de l'énergie
pour pouvoir s'atteler assez assez
difficultés sur l'éclairage public par
exemple depuis 2019 on est déjà à 20%
d'économie le tout alors dans un
contexte vous l'avez dénoncé aussi dans
vos vœux de baisse de dotation de l'État
vous estimez qu'en 10 ans vous l'avez
dit l'État a pris 1,5 millions d'euros à
la commune c'est difficile aujourd'hui
d'agir avec de moins en moins de moyens
pour les maires il faut savoir grosso
modo une rénovation énergétique d'un
bâtiment public on en a au moins pour un
million cinq
donc voilà
voilà où il pourrait passer pour pouvoir
accélérer et répondre à l'enjeu de
changement climatique aujourd'hui il se
trouve que à côté de à côté de ces
enjeux de rénovation de bâti on a aussi
des services publics qu'on rend aux
habitants et c'est dotations ne sont pas
venues de nulle part c'est pas juste un
cadeau de l'État c'était des dotations
qui étaient faites pour
compenser les services publics délégués
par l'État aux communes l'état civil la
gestion des bâties des écoles les routes
tout ça aujourd'hui on doit le faire
mais finalement avec plus d'argent de la
part de l'État on était à peu près à
165 euros par habitant il y a 10 ans en
dotation de l'État aujourd'hui on est à
14,50 €. donc avec quand même une baisse
de dotation de l'État des projets quand
même qui sont en cours on va parler
justement de ces grands projets de
l'année 2023 les nouveautés les nouveaux
dossiers qui pourraient venir sur la
table
il y a un projet en cours dont on parle
depuis plusieurs années c'est cette
rénovation recons du Collège Albert
Einstein est-ce qu'il y aura du nouveau
cette année pour pour le collège Mani
quoi c'est comme vous le dites un gros
dossier depuis longtemps ça fait plus de
10 ans qu'on en parle
ça avait été reporté au fur et à mesure
aujourd'hui on a donc un dossier de
démolition reconstruction de scolaire
avec des matériaux bio sourcés avec une
rénovation du coup énergétique
importante pour pour tout ça avec des
espaces aussi en cours qui seront des
espaces très végétalisés
je remercie le département de s'engager
dans dans cette démarche parce qu'en
plus ça correspond exactement à ce qu'on
demandait au niveau de la commune étant
dans un parc naturel régional pour avoir
quelque chose d'exemplaire en termes de
bâti
on va avoir une réunion jeudi le jury
pour le choix du de l'entreprise qui va
travailler le sujet et ensuite on espère
un démarrage des travaux dans le cas
2025 sachant que ce sont des travaux
lourds impactant à la fois pour les
riverains mais aussi pour les élèves et
l'ensemble du du personnel éducatif
puisque on sera aussi en site occupé
pendant ces travaux donc on se coordonne
avec l'ensemble des départs des services
du département pour pouvoir mener au
mieux ces travaux et ça va être un grand
bonheur une fois que ça sera fait donc
du concret en 2023 et début des travaux
espérés dès l'an prochain peut-être pour
ce collège Einstein Manile amo va aussi
disposer d'une nouvelle médiathèque
alors jusqu'à présent on va pouvoir voir
les images elle était installée au sein
de bâtiment préfabriqué quand sera-t-il
dans les prochains mois du coup comment
ça va évoluer sur ce dossier alors là
aussi c'est un ancien dossier des villes
historiques de de l'ex-ville nouvelle
c'était les derniers bâtiments
préfabriqués pour une médiathèque qui
est de la compétence de l'agglomération
les discussions abouties à une
programmation
sur laquelle également on est totalement
satisfait pour avoir un bâtiment qui
sera aussi au niveau énergétique très
exemplaire et qui permettra aux
habitants d'avoir un lieu public de
lecture qui soit totalement adaptée avec
un agrandissement par rapport à l'état
actuel aujourd'hui le permis de
construire
doit être déposé
et ensuite les démarches administratives
on va dire on espère pouvoir
bénéficier de cette médiathèque d'ici
fin 2024 début 2025 attention sur les
dates par rapport aux travaux
actuellement ça peut être très parce que
en ce moment avec un certain nombre de
pénuries de matériaux de retard de
d'effectifs des entreprises de travaux
publics ça peut parfois prendre
énormément de retard on est à l'abri de
rien il y a un dossier aussi qui est en
suspens et ce bâtiment de la Maison de
l'Environnement qui dont l'agglomération
de 50 ans en ville en Yvelines a mis fin
aux activités sur place aussi depuis
plusieurs années
un nouveau projet qui émerge est-ce que
il y a du nouveau aussi sur sur ce
dossier ce qu'on pourrait voir des
nouveautés en 2023 alors sur ce dossier
là on continue de discuter avec
l'agglomération rien n'est encore rien
n'est encore fait
voilà il se passe quelques événements on
continue discuter aujourd'hui il se
passe en fait quelques événements même
depuis 2015 depuis la Bandon de cette de
ce projet de Maison de l'environnement
par par l'agglomération puisque la
commune
occupe les lieux et finalement permet
que ce lieu ce bâtiment puisse être
utilisé et reste utilisable alors
l'autre projet d'envergure bien sûr pour
la commune c'est cette ligne 18 du Grand
Paris Express le métro doit relier Orly
à Versailles à l'horizon 2030 le tracé
passe par la commune de Magny hameau il
y aura un arrêt à 50 ans en Yvelines au
niveau de la commune de Guyancourt et on
sait que vous avez été opposé au projet
en tout cas vous avez porté aussi un
projet alternatif puisqu'on sait que ce
tracé sur le plateau de Saclay se fera
en aérien est-ce que aujourd'hui vous
avez des moyens d'action est-ce que le
tracé est totalement défini est-ce que
il y a encore des moyens d'action pour
pour le bien vous êtes cette commune de
magny-les-maux il y a aussi d'autres
mères qui étaient opposé à ce projet
ensemble avec les autres mères et les
habitants des autres communes concernées
et les agriculteurs du plateau on
continue d'intervenir au maximum pour
pouvoir permettre que si l'État a choisi
cette ligne et continue de la choisir
quelle passe sur nos territoires sans
abîmer les territoires
en tranchées ouvertes ou couverte au
maximum tout simplement pour des
questions de continuité agricole pour
des questions
d'environnement pour des questions
bruits aussi
sachant que par exemple les les études
qui nous sont montrées aujourd'hui
démontre que les le niveau de bruit est
supérieur aux préconisations l'OMS
aujourd'hui dans 10 ou 20 ans l'État
français devra intégrer ses
préconisations dans la et derrière
qu'est-ce qu'on fait donc ça c'est pas
tranché on peut vous pouvez encore agir
sur le sujet non on fera tout pour
permettre que si l'État continue de
choisir ce cette ligne là dans les
années futures parce que c'est un
programmation 2030 on continuera tout
faire pour que ça ne mette pas en péril
le territoire où ça passe 2027 pour la
partie estonienne 2030 pour la partie
yvelinoise on a vu déjà des premiers
coups de pioche au niveau des communes
de Palaiseau de Saclay est-ce que à
Magny-les-Hameaux il y aura des premiers
travaux cette année c'est où ce sera
plutôt dans les prochaines années priori
non il y a encore une nouvelle enquête
publique puisque les emprises de
chantier et a priori les emprisent qui
seront programmées dans le futur avec
avec ces climats changent au fur et à
mesure des mois donc rien ne semble a
priori stabiliser aujourd'hui alors en
2022 elle m'a mis les hameau on a vu
s'implanter aussi nouvelle structure
c'est graines d'avenir une école qui
permet à des jeunes sans condition
d'accéder à des formations diplômantes
pour le métier de maraîcher primeur
alors la nouveauté en 2023 en tout cas
on l'espère pour 2023 c'est Thierry Marx
qui va normalement implanter sa cuisine
mode d'emploi c'est une cuisine
d'application finalement pour pour le
chef voilà la ferme de bulloyer c'est un
patrimoine incroyable à Manille les
hameau une ferme du 15e siècle et qui
aujourd'hui en train de se transformer
entière lui agricole en entière lieu
d'insertion sociale et en lieu de vie
aussi on a la ferme école avec donc des
jeunes qui apprennent et qui apprennent
ces métiers autour de la production
agricole et de la vente de produits
agricoles et sera adossé donc à cette
ferme école cette cuisine
d'insertion qui va permettre donc
l'apprentissage des métiers de cuisine
et de services évidemment en cuisinant
des produits de la ferme directement
donc on continue de progresser et c'est
et c'est des formations qui sont nickel
aujourd'hui notamment pour nos
territoires pour permettre à des jeunes
d'accéder à des métiers d'avenir qui
sont la production agricole dont on a
énormément besoin et qui sont les
métiers de la restauration dont on a
aussi énormément besoin et un dernier
projet dont je voulais parler avec vous
c'est la maison Madeleine une maison
intergénérationnelle et solidaire qui
devrait voir le jour à la fin de l'année
c'est ça ou en tout cas les travaux vont
débuter cette année l'objectif est un
dépôt de permis sur dans l'année on
accompagne ce dossier porté par une
association qui est un dossier vraiment
innovant qui part sur le principe que
toutes les personnes quel que soit les
conditions quel que soit le niveau
d'autonomie peuvent réussir à vivre
ensemble on a choisi on a acheté un
terrain directement dans le centre bourg
pour permettre à des personnes qui qui
sont plutôt très âgés qui sont en
situation de handicap des familles
monoparentales des jeunes étudiants de
pouvoir vivre ensemble avec chacun sa
partie avec des espaces communs un café
ouvert sur l'extérieur et éventuellement
une crèche aussi pour pour accompagner
tout ça voilà c'est innovant donc qui
dit innovation dit que ça rentre pas
forcément dans toutes les cases
l'habitat inclusive c'est ça
malheureusement aujourd'hui et
l'association essaye de boucler un
certain nombre de financement notamment
par rapport au fonctionnement avec le
département et j'espère qu'on va y
arriver et quels sont les autres grands
dossiers à suivre en 2023 à
Magny-les-Hameaux alors on a un sujet
qui s'appelle ma cour passe au vert qui
est la végétalisation de nos corps
d'écoles pour pouvoir déminéraliser au
maximum tous ces espaces là et lutter
contre les îlots de chaleur c'est c'est
un vaste sujet sur l'ensemble de nos
cours nous avons également un dossier
sur la rénovation énergétique qui est le
gymnase Auguste Delaune qui est en
démolition reconstruction sur une partie
qui est un dossier aussi complexe que
nous menons et on va entamer d'autres
sujets de rénovation énergétique sur une
autre école des cette année avec une
étude et puis on va lancer c'est une
étude sur un réseau de chaleur avec
notre Data Center et les évolutions
technologiques qu'il y a sur ce Data
Center et là encore ça va être un vase
dossier notre objectif et de pouvoir
vérifier si on pourrait via ce data
center
utilisé l'énergie pour recouvrir
l'ensemble des équipements publics voilà
pour les grands dossiers à
Magny-les-Hameaux en 2023 et pour
terminer on passe à l'interview express
[Musique]
donc le principe Bertrand Houillon 5
questions des réponses courtes oui un
nom un pour ou contre parfois quelques
explications je vais vous demander de
les donner en 20 30 secondes grand
maximum et ce qu'en 2023 vous
augmenterez les impôts locaux à
Magny-les-Hameaux le débat d'orientation
budgétaire a lieu au début à la fin du
mois là donc on va étudier tout ça avec
l'ensemble des conseillers municipaux
pour l'instant c'est pas totalement
défini évidemment avec ce qu'on a évoqué
d'évolution budgétaire comme dans
beaucoup de collectivités ça risque
d'être oui alors certaines communes ont
fait le choix de passer à une limitation
de vitesse à 30 km/h c'est le cas de
manier les hameaux de votre expérience
et ce qu'il faudrait l'étendre aux
autres communes est-ce que vous
conseillerez un maire d'une commune
voisine de passer aussi au 30 km/h alors
on l'a défini depuis le 1er décembre
dernier donc on en est encore au tout
début l'ensemble des parties agglomérées
donc des parties en ville de notre de
notre commune sont en zone 30
c'est c'est tout simplement une question
de priorité à partir du moment où on est
en ville où il y a de l'habitat la
priorité au piétons et aux cycliste pour
faire très attention et c'est
les piétons et les cyclistes qui sont
les plus vulnérables sur l'espace public
donc moi je conseillerais à tout le
monde d'y aller pour permettre justement
que ça devienne une règle éventuellement
le bio dans les cantines vous en avez
fait aussi le choix un peu plus de 50%
même 60% de bio dans les cantines
manicoises est-ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre l'obligation du bio dans les
cantines Yvelines dans les cantines
Yvelines et françaises forcément tout le
monde doit y passer pour ma part après
obligation ou pas tout le monde doit y
aller mais au-delà de la question du bio
il y a aussi la question du local
puisque ça sert à rien de faire
traverser la terre entière pour du bio
donc du local de saison et des produits
aussi qui bénéficient d'un certain
nombre de label je pense à la viande par
exemple l'objectif est d'en avoir une
traçabilité vraiment précise de
l'ensemble malheureusement dans
l'actualité on a vu des maires des élus
victimes d'agression ou de menaces
est-ce que dans de vos fonctions vous
avez déjà vous êtes déjà senti en
insécurité
je suis en sécurité non par contre il
m'est arrivé de faire l'objet de menace
d'injure j'ai porté plainte directement
et je remercie les gendarmes pour leur
efficacité et la justice qui est passée
donc c'est très bien et si vous êtes en
heureux dernière question oui très
heureux et entouré avec plein de gens
formidables et notamment les habitants
de la commune merci Bertrand Houillon
d'avoir été avec nous je le rappelle
maire de la commune de Magny-les-Hameaux
est très bonne année 2023 dans votre
commune merci
[Musique]
retour en direct et retour aussi du
d'une personne qui nous fait le plaisir
de venir chaque mardi sur le plateau du
7 8 c'est Véronique Ithurbide bonsoir on
a remarqué oui ça va ça va très bien et
vous merci super vite les informations
insolites les insolites de Véronique les
informations qu'on a peut-être raté et
qui sortent un peu de l'ordinaire dans
les Yvelines on en parlera dans un
instant il y a toujours aussi Valentin
de la porte qui est avec nous qui est
directeur adjoint de la Bergerie
Nationale je le disais la bergerie qui
organise deux journées portes ouvertes
la première c'est ce samedi un 28
janvier la prochaine ce sera le 11 mars
à chaque fois les horaires 9h 17h et
l'objectif c'est de découvrir les
formations qui sont regroupées proposées
sur place combien de jeunes se forment à
la Bergerie Nationale en moyennement on
a environ 400 apprenants chaque année
comme ils sont en alternance ils sont
pas tous sur le site en même temps mais
on a plus 25% par rapport à il y a deux
trois ans grâce au boom de
l'apprentissage alors les jeunes j'en ai
pas ouvertes vont permettre de découvrir
les trois filières proposées à la
bergerie quels sont justement ces trois
filières alors il y a la filière épique
avec les formations de personnes qui
sont salariés dans des entreprises
hippiques et puis d'enseignant
d'équitation ensuite il y a la filière
agricole avec des formations de BTS
agricole pour être salarié ou conseillé
agricoles ou agriculteurs
notamment en élevage et puis une licence
production animale pour travailler dans
des coopératives agricoles niveau
supérieur et puis la dernière partie
c'est la santé animale d'accord et les
animaux de compagnie avec la formation
des assistantes vétérinaires on a
beaucoup de jeunes qui qui viennent pour
cela et aussi des formations un peu plus
courtes soit sur la reproduction soit
sur
des certifications qui permettent d'être
professionnels dans
au milieu là formation en alternance
formation continue aussi les deux
possibilités alors le gros des
formations sont en alternance ce sont
des apprentis donc des salariés ils sont
payés pour travailler chez leur patron
et venir chez nous au CFA accroître leur
connaissance théorique et puis on a de
la formation continue qui est un peu
moins en ce moment
parce que les gens se dirigent vers
l'apprentissage
mais des formations courtes qui peuvent
intéresser pas mal de gens je vous dis
pour travailler les animaux de compagnie
la reproduction est-ce que il y a du
travail dans ces filières est-ce que ça
embauche oui c'est des filières en
tension ils cherchent des personnes et
on forme pas assez de gens par rapport à
la demande donc en agriculture il y a un
besoin de renouvellement très important
et
il faut absolument que les jeunes
passionnés d'animaux de culture
viennent chez nous voir découvrir ce que
l'on peut y faire non parmi les métiers
il y a celui de berger notamment la
semaine dernière se tenait la finale du
meilleur John Berger d'Île-de-France
c'était à la Bergerie Nationale une
quinzaine de candidats ce sont frottés à
des épreuves théoriques et pratiques
indirectement inspiré des gestes
quotidiens de l'éleveur vous étiez sur
place Saint-Nicolas dansi effectivement
c'est c'est assez impressionnant en fait
tous les gestes techniques qui a à voir
lorsque l'on hébergé et notamment rien
que pour asseoir une brebis mais bon je
n'en dis pas plus vous allez voir ça
dans le reportage reportage que vous
avez réalisé avec Mathilde Franco
je me trouve à La Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet pour la finale régionale
d'Île-de-France du meilleur jeune berger
ils sont à peu près une quinzaine de
candidats de la Bergerie Nationale a
passé ce concours ils ont plusieurs
épreuves à passer en va découvrir
lesquels ensemble est-ce que elle me
tourne le dos est-ce qu'un petit mot
pour
[Musique]
la belle je vais faire la
l'état de santé donc ça consiste à
évaluer l'état de santé de la brebis
donc on va regarder à l'arrière les
dents les paupières qu'on regarde de ta
santé générale de l'animal
vu qu'elle a l'air elle doit sûrement
avoir attrapé une
diarrhée donc à surveiller on surveille
au niveau de la Corporelle de l'animal
ça doit être à combien normalement à
température
[Musique]
parce que j'aime bien être en extérieur
j'aime bien j'aime bien faire tout le
temps quelque chose de différent j'aime
pas la routine c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose de plutôt complet et
j'adore les animaux
[Musique]
et je me trouve avec Manon Batista
ancien élève de la Bergerie Nationale
qui avait participé aux Olympiades
l'année dernière qui est maintenant
bergère à la Bergerie Nationale alors
Manon qu'est-ce que ça fait maintenant
d'être jury bah c'est une action
personnelle parce que c'est vrai que
participer à un concours comme ça et
puis faire les Olympiades nationales et
maintenant à juger c'est vrai que c'est
une concrétisation c'est cool c'est
compliqué de juger maintenant ou alors
qu'avant tu faisais les épreuves pas
tant que ça je dirais même que c'est
presque plus facile parce que je sais ce
que ça fait d'être en face et alors Anne
Séverine François vous l'avez formé
pareil c'est une fierté pour vous de
l'avoir évolué et devenir bergère oui
bien sûr Manon je l'ai suivi donc
pendant son BTS et des années de BTS
l'an dernier je l'ai accompagné aux
Olympiades jusqu'au salon de
l'agriculture et maintenant j'ai la
chance de travailler avec elle donc
c'est voilà c'est toujours plaisant en
fait de déjà de voir que ces élèves
réussissent et puis après de aussi à
travailler avec eux
[Musique]
et les deux meilleures candidats de
cette finale régionale pourront
participer à la finale nationale du
meilleur jeune berger elle aura lieu au
salon de l'agriculture fin février
[Musique]
et justement en bonne nouvelle les deux
représentants de l'île de France sont
ivinois il s'agit de calisttement sud de
Gabriel perron tous deux élèvent à la
Bergerie Nationale qui vont donc
affronter 38 autres candidats c'est une
fierté j'imagine pour la bergerie on est
très fiers on est très fier que ça se
des jeunes filles on forme énormément de
jeunes filles et tant mieux c'est bien
pour l'agriculture et elles sont très
performantes alors j'espère que pour
avoir un bon résultat à la finale
nationale Nicolas très très belle
matinée en compagnie des brebis et puis
on a vu le talent de Mathilde Franco qui
qui murmure à l'oreille des brebis qui
parlent même au brebis donc quel talent
j'étais vraiment des journalistes
talentueux à la rédaction grand
passionné de chevaux mais aussi
visiblement de brebis
ça permet de mettre en lumière aussi ces
professions oui alors on s'y remet
notamment sur la profession de berger on
a une vieille tradition depuis 1784 on a
des bergers à la Bergerie Nationale donc
ça fait un bout de temps et on avait un
peu perdu cette vue en tout cas on
arrivait plus à transférer nos
compétences à des jeunes et là c'est
reparti il y a énormément de jeunes qui
sont intéressés par l'élevage tant mieux
ça va ça augure de bonnes années pour
l'élevage français mouton vache cochon
et on pourra découvrir tous ces métiers
lors des journées portes ouvertes quel
est le programme il y a la première qui
se déroule samedi il y en aurait une
autre le 11 mars quel est le programme
de ces journées alors l'intérêt de ces
journées c'est qu'on peut rencontrer les
formateurs les personnes qui en cas de
la vie scolaire en général au cas par
cas pour affiner le projet scolaire voir
sur quelle formation s'orienter
et visiter l'ensemble du site y compris
l'exploitation agricole le centre
équestre et l'ensemble de nos bâtiments
historiques et samedi donc c'est
uniquement en présentiel le 11 mars il y
aura possibilité de suivre les journées
également à distance oui c'est une
grande spécialité chez nous le
distanciel on a on a fait du 100%
distanciel pendant les confinements ça
s'est très bien passé et en fait on y a
pris goût et les personnes nous
demandent aussi de faire des
présentations de distanciels pareil ça
va être des échanges en direct avec les
personnes qui pourront nous poser leurs
questions
ce 11 mars avec toute notre équipe de
formateurs et donc toutes les
informations à retrouver bien sûr sur le
site internet de La Bergerie Nationale
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
Valentin de la porte de nous avoir
expliqué tout ça vous restez avec nous
et on ouvre à présent une page culture
dans ce 7 8
[Musique]
la culture et les insolites avec
Véronique pour commencer les insolites
de la semaine qui ont retenu votre
attention et on commence par une bonne
nouvelle pour les fans de Chouchou ceux
qui ont regardé aussi un gars une fille
voilà à qui je fais allusion je pense
que vous avez vous avez compris c'est
évidemment à Alexandra Lamy qu'on va
pouvoir voir en chair et en os un vrai
voilà moi j'ai un petit côté people
j'aime bien voir les vedettes en vrai
donc pour ça il faut aller se pas
compliqué à l'UGC par l'idée au Chesnay
dimanche 29 janvier à 15h parce qu'il y
aura le film d'Eric barbier qui
s'appelle alors toujours envie de dire
tout et bohu c'est pas du tout ça c'est
zodi et tu pardon les frères du désert
c'est l'histoire de dromadaire pour
changer des brebis et donc c'est une
jolie histoire d'un petit garçon qui est
drief le l'acteur donc il se représente
Alexandra Lamy il y a cédrief Eric
Barbie réalisateur donc c'est une
histoire entre un petit garçon et un
dromadaire un dromadaire qui a des
grosses grosses qualités de coureurs
parce qu'il y a des gens très longues
vous êtes au courant bah je j'ai déjà vu
la bande-annonce mais
bon bref c'est un film tout public qui a
l'air très très chouette et je vous
encourage à y aller c'est l'occasion de
découvrir ce film de aussi faire la
rencontre de l'équipe du film de poser
des questions c'était toujours agréable
toujours agréable on continue avec une
revue qui vous a scotché ça s'appelle
Les Carnets de Versailles on va faire un
3 en 1 est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
ce que c'est que ce qu'est cette revue
je vais y arriver commence la Procure et
ce qu'elle contient alors bah vous coûte
chose donc ça s'appelle Les Carnets de
Versailles alors là j'ai l'impression de
de d'avoir découvert quelque chose mais
en fait non ça existe depuis assez
longtemps au numéro 21 c'est un magazine
semestriel voilà qui est édité par le
château de Versailles et vous avez à la
fois l'intérieur des des articles de
fonds en général en rapport avec
l'actualité donc là on a l'exposition
Louis XV enfin il y a plein de choses
vous avez des photos des programmations
l'agenda et ce qui est génial c'est que
c'est complètement gratuit donc en fait
vous pouvez vous sur le site les carnets
de versailles.fr vous avez un coupon
d'abonnement à remplir et vous recevrez
gratuitement tous les semestres votre
votre magazine pas du tout je
connaissais pas du tout et du coup on le
dit c'est pas distribué
gratuitement c'est Lucie Nicolas William
qui m'a dit tout ça c'est la rédacteur
en chef du journal alors à l'intérieur
comme je vous ai dit c'est très riche
vous avez par exemple là en rapport avec
l'exposition Louis XV qui se termine le
19 février entre parenthèses des
péchons-nous pour ceux qui l'ont pas vu
vous avez par exemple Julia cristella à
qui on a la psychanalyste à qui on a
devant demander de psychanalyser c'est
du radier Louis XV donc sur le divan
elle s'est aidé d'un portrait de duc de
Luynes alors Louis XV n'était ni vif et
plutôt atrabilaire un peu obsédé par la
mort et bon ben voilà c'est comme ça et
puis il y a aussi autre chose que j'ai
découvert c'est
des photos magnifiques qui ont été
faites par Jérémy Villet qui est un donc
je passe à mon troisième sujet Jérémy
Villet oui on peut découvrir ces photos
on m'a écrit les rôles on se voit là
pour être tout à fait honnête avec les
téléspectateurs
c'est pas grave Véronique c'est les
insolites de Véronique à chaque fois sur
tv70 il a été hébergé dans la maison du
jardinier près du Grand Trianon pour
pouvoir commencer dès l'aube et terminer
son travail dans la nuit exactement
merci alors du coup c'est un jeune
yvelino imaginez-vous qui a grandi dans
une ferme dans les Yvelines et c'est là
où il a acquéri ce goût de la nature la
vie sauvage et il y a 10 ans maintenant
il est il s'est destiné à la profession
enfin sa passion photographe animalier
voilà en 2019 il a sorti un livre qui
s'appelle première neige donc lui son sa
spécialité c'est plutôt les étendues
nageuses le Grand Nord etc mais là les
carnets de Versailles lui ont demandé de
prendre possession des lieux donc du
parc une fois le public Party et
d'ailleurs il raconte que dès que le
public est parti les animaux sortent et
il a des photos sont dans ce carnet et
sont aussi sur le site les carnet de
Versailles qui apporte au lieu vous
pouvez voir toutes les photos qu'il a
prises magnifiques alors évidemment il y
a un écosystème incroyable c'est des
serres des renards des lièvres tout un
tas d'oiseaux et ce qui est génial c'est
que c'est un décor quand même
particulier entre le château les statues
et il y a une espèce de corrélation et
notamment une photo d'un oiseau qui est
la statue de cheval comme l'impression
que le cheval le regarde vraiment ça
rend vivant les statuts et ça leur donne
un mouvement quel nom évidemment pas
voilà mais si on veut en savoir plus sur
lui on peut regarder le sur le site de
France 2 il y a les paradis blanc c'est
le paradis blanc qui ont été diffusés
mais ça monte par Laurent Delahousse
tout à fait dans son magazine 13h15 le
dimanche il se trouve que vous avez
quatre épisodes de 20 minutes qui sont
c'est donc un documentaire sur Jérémy
Villers qui a été suivi de la Norvège
jusque dans les Yvelines sa fameuse
ferme où il a vécu et là on voit des
rencontres
insolite incroyable alors avec quelques
humains mais surtout beaucoup d'animaux
sauvages dont notamment un loup et
franchement c'est ces photos sont pas
belles mais juste sublime Facebook
plaisir et allez voir bon merci
Véronique pour une prochaine pour nous
en faire partager d'autres
questions est-ce que vous êtes fan de
lecture est-ce que vous avez un livre de
chevet en ce moment
oui moi un livre sur les tortues un
livre sur les tortues Nicolas moi c'est
un livre de rugby livre de Véronique et
moi c'est un roman anglo-saxon
d'Elizabeth Struth
les nuits de la lecture c'était le
week-end dernier et notamment à 50 ans
en Yvelines on a pu frissonner pendant
quatre soirées puisque l'objectif c'est
de mettre en lumière la lecture sous
toutes ses formes avec une thématique
cette année c'est pour ça que j'ai dit
frissonner c'était la peur récit
d'histoires effrayante ou encore flash
mob flash mob orific Mélanie pocket
Julien Leroy ont suivi les rendez-vous
dans les médiathèques de 50 ans en
Yvelines
abracada
hier j'avais peur du noir ambiance
angoissante pour cette deuxième édition
des Nuits de la lecture organisation 51
en Yvelines objectif de C4 soirée
partagez le plaisir de lire et
frissonner autour d'histoire aux
effrayantes est-ce que si les lumières
de la rue sont éteintes vous avez peur
il y a beaucoup d'enfants courageux ici
c'est samedi 21 janvier le jeune public
de la médiathèque Anatole France attrape
voyagé à travers des lectures musicales
récit sur la peur du noir ou
d'apparition surnaturelle
[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup aimé le mariage entre
raconter des histoires et la musique
c'était très très sympa toute la famille
on manque pas de support sur la peur sur
ce thème là sur ce thème là et
contrairement aux idées préconçues qu'on
soit jeune ado adulte tout le monde lit
et tout le monde aime la lecture la nuit
tombée laissée place à une ambiance
festive et horrifique du côté de la
médiathèque du canal à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux visite décalée de
l'établissement décorés pour l'occasion
mais aussi un Flash Mob sur la danse de
mercredi à Talence
ça nous permet de donner à voir la
médiathèque autrement en soirée voilà
c'est une toute autre ambiance que dans
la journée valoriser énormément le
loisir en médiathèque de plus en plus et
voilà ça permet de toucher de nouveaux
publics qui pourraient être un peu
effrayé par par le lieu ça permet de se
rassembler et de découvrir des nouvelles
lectures pour les enfants et donner le
goût de lire parce qu'aujourd'hui avec
l'avènement de tous les réseaux sociaux
la lecture voilà il faut encourager la
lecture c'est un divertissement mais
aussi un moyen d'apprentissage des fois
ça peut être ennuyant comme les livres
de cours mais souvent quand je lis pour
moi bah du plaisir cette nouvelle
édition organisée par le Centre national
du livre a permis de fédérer 8000
événements dans près de 4000 lieux en
France et à l'étranger prochain grand
rendez-vous en mars prochain pour le
Printemps des Poètes dans les
médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
[Applaudissements]
bientôt 19h il est presque l'heure de
passer à table
avec le nouvel an chinois qui a débuté
depuis dimanche 2 semaines de festivités
pour célébrer la nouvelle année celle du
lapindo et à cette occasion TV 78
essayer de dédier son astuce du chef à
la gastronomie chinoise nous sommes
allés voir le restaurant faux 78 qui
nous a livré sa recette de gâteau de riz
sauté c'est un plat traditionnel du
nouvel an du nouvel an chinois qui trône
au centre de votre table et des tables
chinoises pendant le nouvel an et c'est
l'astuce du chef du jour
[Musique]
bonjour je suis Sousou je suis le
responsable de faux 78 aujourd'hui je
vous présente une recette le riz gâteau
de riz nature sauté avec le chef zoo
[Musique]
notre gâteau de riz sauté c'est prêt
notre astuce il faut ajouter de l'eau de
temps en temps au palais sur les gâteaux
de riz ça colle avec le pot donc voilà
bon appétit
[Musique]
bon ça semble presque facile vous allez
vous y essayez Valentin de la princesse
de gastronomie asiatique chinoise plus
particulièrement oui et autour de la
table est-ce que vous aimez ce genre de
mais est-ce que vous allez vous
vous allez le déguster sur place
de la rédaction de TV 78 Nicolas on a la
chance d'y manger régulièrement c'est
vrai que en plus on a pu déguster le
plat puisque Mathilde en arabé quelques
morceaux donc voilà pour cette suite
c'était bon mais ce côté salé sucré salé
qui fait la richesse de la gastronomie
chinois c'est vrai que c'est moi en tout
cas j'y suis con voilà la semaine
dernière c'était la gastronomie
italienne gastronomie chinoise la
semaine prochaine voyage également tout
en restant dans les Yvelines ici sur ce
plateau de TV 78 voilà c'est la bientôt
la fin du 7 8 avant de se quitter on va
jeter un dernier coup d'œil à la météo
de demain
et des conditions météo semblables à
celles d'aujourd'hui il y aura également
peut-être demain matin du brouillard
dans les Yvelines côté température il
fera moins 1 degré à Mantes-la-Jolie ou
dans les Rambouillet 0° à Versailles
dans l'après-midi quelques éclaircies
prévus mais ça reste froid il fera 2
degrés à Versailles un degré Rambouillet
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan ce mercredi 25
janvier nous fêterons les pôles voilà
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de votre
fidélité et on se retrouve dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]